figure live bonjour nous sommes en
direct ce vendredi matin pour vous
parler de la guerre en ukraine et je
suis avec alexis faire chaque
journaliste adjoint au pôle actu du
figaro bonjour alexis bonjour à 100 avec
vous on va revenir un peu sur sur sur ce
qui se passe sur ce qui se passe depuis
cinq mois puisque ça fait cinq mois un
peu plus maintenant que la guerre a
débuté n'hésitez pas à bien évidemment à
poser vos questions on va s'appuyer bien
évidemment sur les cartes notre service
infographie que vous pouvez voir ici on
va parler un peu de tous ces sujets le
fond du sud le front de l'est
particulièrement alexis déjà une
question un peu générale comment évolue
la situation pour l'instant pour de
résumer de manière très simple c'est une
carte qui
des du conflit et qui est à jour et bien
franchement si on avait pris la même
carte ya un mois globalement elle aurait
été la même puisque là les
suffisamment à
grande échelle pour qu'on ne voit pas
tellement les avancées qui ont été lents
de de quelques kilomètres où quelques
dizaines de kilomètres pour prendre un
ordre de grandeur les les russes
contrôlent 130 milles entre 120 et 130
mille kilomètres carrés
de l'ukraine mais y compris avec des
territoires qui ont été pris en 2014
écrit mais une partie du thon basse est
aujourd'hui un peu en juillet ils ont
avancé de quelques dizaines voire
centaines de kilomètres carrés donc
c'est une partie infinitésimale du total
et donc on voit bien qu'il ya une il ya
une sorte d' enlisement des dents là
dans les changements delà de la ligne de
front qui se qui se stabilise ça c'est
là la principale
information
de cette semi août sachant que ya en
fait deux fronts l'offensive russe dans
l'est de l'ukraine dans le donbass donc
le dôme assez de the blaze de lougansk
et dounia sq alors les russes ont fini
de prendre le blast 2 2 de lougansk il
plus à l'est mais il leur reste la
moitié entre guillemets de le blast de
dounia ceapro à récupérer va prendre et
hélas il n'avance plus ces dernières
semaines ou très peu et puis l'autre
offensif qui en fait une contre
offensive ukrainienne lc dans le sud de
l'ukraine dans la région de kherson
voyez il ya le fleuve nieppe requis qui
traverse cette scène région car ce n'est
ni au niveau de l'embouchure du du
nieppe et l objectif le premier objectif
des ukrainiens ça serait de repousser
les russes de l'autre côté d'unia c'est
à dire à l'aise d'y être mais là encore
on a annoncé cette offensive d'été
depuis des semaines et même en réalité
depuis depuis des mois et pour l'instant
la ligne de front n'a absolument pas
changé la ligne de front grosso modo
celui là l'est pas indiquée mais c'est
la ligne de front se fuient une rivière
les lignes lille net et
et grosso modo les choses n'ont pas
avancé les ukrainiens ont une tête de
pont sur cette rivière mais non mais non
pas réussi à avancer dans la dans la
profondeur du dispositif russe donc
reste à voir maintenant si c'est quelque
chose de de stam de structurel sicile la
guerre finalement atteint ce que
clausewitz appelait un point culminant
et que maintenant bas ça va rester le
rapport de force militaire va rester
ainsi ou si on va assister à la
contre-offensive ukrainienne à carson et
si l'offensive russe dans le donbass
va finalement ray avant c'est oui parce
que cette c'est cette fameuse
contre-offensive ukrainienne nous vous
le disiez c'était annoncé depuis
longtemps le ministre de chrétiens de la
défense je crois en lui et oui et
zelensky on parle énormément ce qui est
intéressant c'est que plus on descend si
en plus on s'éloigne de la hiérarchie
politique pourra vert pour aller vers la
hiérarchie militaire
on est beaucoup plus prudents avec les
militaires ukrainiens sont tout à fait
conscients des des difficultés pour
mener une telle offensive encore une
fois des contre attaques extrêmement
localisé c'est possible et les
ukrainiens le font tous les jours mais
une contre offensive c'est autre chose
alors pour plusieurs raisons il ya des
raisons qui sont liées au terrain
toute cette région de l'embouchure du
nieppe re ce sont des grandes plaines
des grandes plaines extrêmement plate
dont convoiterait également loin
qu'ils sont peu densément peuplées il ya
simplement des pleins de petits villages
sur la ligne de front beaucoup
d'ailleurs fonds sont en réalité vide
d'habitants où il ya très peu
d'habitants qui sont qui sont restés et
donc toutes grandes
manoeuvres avec des forces importantes
se verrait et donc ça laisserait au
défenseur les le la possibilité de
répondre à cette attaque donc ça on va
dire c'est ce qui est lié au terrain et
ensuite il ya ce qui est lié à
l'équilibré des forces dans cette région
les ukrainiens au niveau général du pays
ils ont peut être un avantage en nombre
d'hommes en tout cas un nombre théorique
d'hommes pourquoi parce qu'ils ont sonné
la mobilisation générale que les russes
ne l'ont pas fait et que les rues sont
envahies l'ukraine avec 150 à 200 mille
deux cent mille hommes et là dessus il
ya une il ya une attrition il faut
compenser les forces qui ont été perdus
donc on est toujours dans les mêmes en
demandent mais en revanche il ya quand
même un rapide rapport de force en
termes de masse qui plaide en faveur de
la russie que ce soit pour l'artillerie
les blindés les chats et surtout la via
l'aviation les russes n'ont pas réussi à
détruire complètement l'aviation
ukrainienne mais mais les ukrainiens
peuvent mener une sorte de petite
guérilla
aérienne on le voit avec des avions
d'attaqué au sol sukhoï 25
ils ont même encore quelques chasseurs
dé on a vu des mines 29 hier qu'ils
volaient en rase-mottes mais ils n'ont
absolument pas les moyens d'une attaque
d'ampleur dans la profondeur du
dispositif russes et ça a mené une
offensive sans aviation
c'est extrêmement extrêmement difficile
mais parce que quand on récupère du sud
du territoire il faut savoir le défendre
et c'est pour ça aussi que les
ukrainiens ils sont là ils sont il fit
frappe autour de carson si les lignes de
ravitaillement oui alors ça ça ils
essayent le fond qui revient en fait les
ukrainiens
paradoxe on parle énormément et a raison
des moyens d'artillerie extrêmement
précis et désormais à la longue portée
donc la longue portée dans l'artillerie
c'est 70 80 km totalement les high mars
américain qui allie portée et précision
et donc ça ça permet de taper les points
névralgiques pour le ravitaillement par
exemple les ponts et notamment les ponts
sur le sur le dniepr il y en a très peu
ils ont tous été
au moins abîmée donc les russes vont
devoir reposer maintenant sur des sur
leur pontonniers pour faire passer des
des ponts flottants ce qui est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus délicat les
ukrainiens peuvent taper également les
les convois ils payent ils peuvent aussi
cibler les états-majors donc ça ça et
surtout les dépôts de munitions ça on a
vu énormément de dépôt de munitions
conques ont sauté dans tout le sud de
l'ukraine donc ça ça a un effet
considérable
notamment pour entraver les russes et la
capacité de
dav et de davance des russes mais en
revanche là où les ukrainiens ont un
problème c'est que leur armée à
l'origine reposé essentiellement voire
quasiment exclusivement sur des
armements qui était soviétique et donc
notamment sur des sur des pièces
d'artillerie soviétique et là ils ont
plus de munitions puiser là ils n'ont
plus de munitions puisqu'ils n'ont plus
vraiment les capacités d'en produire et
que ses ministres sont spécifiques les
calibres ne sont pas les mêmes c'est du
152 mm et pas du
555 du 123 pas du 120 etc et donc ils
n'ont plus de munitions soviétique est
donc en pleine guerre pendant un conflit
ils doivent passer à un autre type
d'armement désarmement occidentaux donc
ça c'est c'est un défi logistique
considérable c'est à dire que c'est
faisable s'ils ont un petit nombre de
pièces d'artillerie et pour prendre un
exemple d ail mars américain
ça se compte en
unités ou
ou allez peut-être entre 10 et 20
maximum avec le nombre correspond au
nombre de munitions c'est à dire pas
énorme les français ont livré une
dizaine de canon caesar
etc etc et surtout céder des moyens qui
sont éparpillés çà vous aviez des
obusiers allemand des obusiers
polonais etc etc donc et si vous voulez
il ya un problème pour les ukrainiens
c'est de faire de la de la guérilla pour
entraver les russes oui dans une logique
défensive mais en revanche monté
soudainement une force
massive pour pour mener une véritable
offensive là c'est autre chose et les
russes ont eu le temps de
renforcer leur défense
dans toute la région de kherson donc
franchement la plupart des analystes
militaires ne crois pas tellement à une
grande offensive
une chrétienne dans le sud de l'ue de de
l'ukraine zelensky a même rappelé hier
que l'objectif ultime des ukrainiens
c'était la reprise de la crimée
franchement aujourd'hui les conditions
de possibilité d'une telle offensive ne
sont pas là ne serait ce que pour une
raison c'est qu'officiellement pour les
russes la crimée c'est la russie et donc
il serait amené à juger si les
ukrainiens franchissez cette frontière
les ruses réagir et il y aura
mobilisation générale et mobilisation
dernier râle et potentiellement une
escalade nucléaire donc c'est pas un
scénario possible est même allé au-delà
du nieppe pour les ukrainiens
actuellement ça paraît difficile la
question c'est est ce que il arriverait
dans les semaines mois qui viennent a
repoussé les russes au delà d'une y être
pour ça il faudrait vraiment qu'ils
cassent complètement les capacités
logistiques russe et que les que les
russes finissent par parce
par se retirer se replier parce que ça
serait un coup pour eux qui serait trop
important de conserver ces deux régions
et ça serait une défaite politique
terrible pour le kremlin parce que
carson c'est la seule capitale régionale
en dehors de données assez l'ouganda les
prises qui avait été président et 2014
mais depuis le 24 février 2022 la seule
capitale régionale occupée par les
russes c'est carson donc ça serait une
défaite politique pour le kremlin une
défaite importante alors on après sa
demande et qui nous dit selon les
enquêtes qui étaient selon les enquêtes
qui est à la base du bombardement de la
centrale de zaporizhya les russes ou les
ukrainiens l'on va parler effectivement
de cette centrale parce que c'est un
point important de cette semaine est-ce
qu'on peut rappeler déjà qu'est ce qui
s'est passé dans cette centrale c'est
cesser une centrale nucléaire quatre
équipes qui a été très rapidement on va
dire prise dès le début dès les premiers
jours du mois de mars la centrale
nucléaire des nero d'art donc dans la
région de zaporijia est légèrement au
sud de la ville de happo ridja a été
prise par les rues se souvient
d'ailleurs il avait ciblé non pas la
centrale elle-même mais des bâtiments
adjacents ont déjà ce moment là on avait
beaucoup parlé des questions de sécurité
nucléaire et donc depuis la centrale est
tenue est occupée par les russes alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est la position
géographique de cette centrale on sait
que souvent les centrales nucléaires
sont proches des fleuves ou des rivières
pour des questions de refroidissement
du combustible et en l'occurrence nro
darel longe le dniepr et donc s'ils
voulaient toute la zone autour d'un
point de vue terrestre tout autour c'est
les russes y a pas de doute là-dessus en
revanche elle est juste en face de
territoire on va dire entraîneur o
d'arrêt écrivirent et qui sont retenues
par les ukrainiens et donc les
ukrainiens et les russes s'accusent
mutuellement
de mettre en danger la sécurité
nucléaire elle en a peu d'informations
précises d'ailleurs les autorités
internationales
selon l'onu
nous ne venons pas qualifié pour
l'instant de ces attaques en dix ans
elles sont russe ou ukrainienne
ce qui est certain il ya deux choses qui
sont certaine c'est qu'il ya des
échanges d'artilleries pas forcé pas sur
la centrale elle-même tout cas autour et
on les alentours ayant fait
ccca qui était craint dès le début c'est
un accident en fait qui évidemment une
vie d'amour affronte autour un accident
peut arriver ça peut toucher pour lui
alors gelé après faut pas être
catastrophistes alors il faut se tenir à
ce que dit la e1 et comme je peux dire
de bêtises les citer précisément c'est
pas de menace immédiate mais ça pourrait
changer à tout moment voilà ça c'était
le directeur général de l'aïe va rafael
grossi qu'anissa hier au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu parce qu'il y avait
une réunion qui avait été
organisé d'ailleurs à la demande
de la russie
alors en fait il ya deux choses c'est
que ces échanges d'artillerie
aussi c'est l'illustration d'une
négociation politique entre la russie et
l'ukraine c'est à dire que les russes
font quelque chose qui d'ailleurs est
interdit par le droit des conflits armés
ou droit
international humanitaire qui est le
fait don d
dans des bâtiments
particulièrement risqué d'y mettre des
forces militaires ce qui transforme des
bâtiments civils ont des bâtiments
militaires et donc on a très bien vu sur
les photos de satellites que les russes
il a probablement pas mal de munitions
dans la centrale nucléaire et ça ne
s'est pas illogique irrationnelle d'un
point de vue militaire puisque savent
très bien que les ukrainiens ne vont pas
oser il grosse frappe et comme justement
on en parlait il y avait tous les dépôts
de munitions rude ce qu ont sauté sur
dernières semaines voilà on peut
imaginer cela est par ailleurs ce que
disent les ukrainiens c'est que les
russes
tap
depuis on va dire la zone de la centrale
nucléaire
vers au delà du
lumière avec des moyens d'artillerie
avec des lance roquettes multiples etc
et les russes en phase vise attendez
vous les ukrainiens vous nous attaquez
vous attaquez vous mettez en danger in
zone
en attaquant d une zone nucléaire est là
aussi avec des moyens d'artillerie des
lance-roquettes multiples la vérité
probablement un peu des deux côtés
ce qui est certain c'est que les
d'ailleurs les six étaient avérés
ce sont deux choses qui sont tout les
deux illégales du point de vue du droit
des confirmés et celle qu'on appelle
dans ce cas là si c'est tout là toute la
complexité de l'exciter de la chose
c'est qu'on n'a pas le droit
en droit d confiera mais c'est très
clair on ne peut attaquer que des
objectifs militaires on va en parler
avait à propos du rapport d'amnesty
international met donc la base du droit
international si on ne peut attaquer que
des objectifs militaires
est un objectif militaire ce qui est à
ceux qui a un intérêt
militaire pour l'assaillant
alors ça peut être un bâtiment civil
mais mais mais à condition qu'il y ait
pas de civils de noé mais guerriers
rebelles militaires et qu'il ya un
intérêt à dire stratégique
néanmoins il ya des exceptions dans un
certain nombre de biens particuliers
alors notamment les hôpitaux qui sont
très très protégée et puis surtout les
bâtiments qui présentent un risque
systémique de faim naturel donc pas un
plat mains d'un barrage d'eau ou non ou
une centrale nucléaire et c'est donc ce
que font les ukrainiens c'est illégal du
point de vue du droit international
humanitaire mais ce que font les russes
c'est aussi les c'est aussi illégal
parce qu'on n'a pas le droit de profiter
justement
de la protection d'un tel bien pour en
profiter pour s'y mettre pour mettre un
état-major des dépôts de munitions voire
200 de s'en servir pour pour faire des
frappes d'artillerie donc voilà la
situation elle est là maintenant
politiquement
parce que ce qui est intéressant c'est
que l'ukraine refuse pour l'instant une
visite de l'eeie a dans la centrale
pourquoi pas ce qu'ils veulent ils
exquise ce que les ukrainiens exige
c'est une zone démilitarisée
autour de la centrale d'énergie
d'artistes ya c'est d'ailleurs ce que
demandent également
les occidentaux et les russes ne veulent
pas
et alors pourquoi d'ailleurs les
ukrainiens se sont exprimés à ce propos
pourquoi ils ne veulent pas que la ive à
hay actuellement la centrale d'énergie
d'assez comme actuellement elle est
tenue par les russes
en réalité ça légitimerait politiquement
la présence russe
donc dans cette centrale est aujourd'hui
ce qu'il ya c'est que les russes veulent
reliés pour l'instant le la centrale est
relié au réseau d'électricité
d'ukrainiens et maintenant ils veulent
relier
la centrale d'énergie d'art ils veulent
la relier au réseau l'ukraine aurait
donc ré maire de calais donc en toute
lumière ruse dans les fans depuis 2014
et il faut rappeler aussi que c'est une
centrale nucléaire qui est très
importante et ça peut aller très
important c'est la plus grande d'europe
il ya six réacteurs nucléaires c'est
continuer ainsi si on les quinze
que compte l'ukraine je peux dire de
bêtises mais je crois que c'est 20% de
l'électricité ukrainienne donc autant
vous dire que s'il y avait un accident
et c'est évidemment saxe surveille les
yeux c'est que dans ces cas là on ne
peut pas
exclure un accident on vient d'une
erreur de viser que sais-je
donc c'est inquiétant mais voilà prêt
faut se tenir à ce que dit là il va pour
l'instant pas de menace imminente voilà
donc
pour l'instant effectivement on a
bonjour chez vous qui est libre je suis
heureux d'entendre finalement quelqu'un
qui ne raconte pas des bêtises mais sur
le figaro monde raconte pas de bêtises
non vous donne de l'information pouvait
nous lire habituellement vous le savez
une question de la garde elle est fille
2022 qui nous dit qu'ils étaient
contents de nous retrouver je pense
qu'il a été déjà là pour nos pour tous
ne l'aï vu que nous faisons souffle
entre sa ville et entend qu'on n'ait pas
fait de deux petits points effectivement
ça faisait plus d'un mois qu'on a passé
ce petit point mais comme on le disait
ça n'a pas forcément beaucoup avancé il
nous demandait est ce que une aide
peut-on imaginer une aide intérieur dans
kherson une contre offensive majeure ou
deux puis à l'importance de mettre aux
ukrainiens d'attendre voire en cercle et
se dire une guérilla urbaine qui se
créerait pas ce que vous êtes pour pour
personnes dialysées les habitants
craignant qu'ils habitent
tout ça c'est un point
très intéressant il faut vraiment
répondre au conditionnel parce que c'est
très difficile d'avoir des informations
là-dessus mais pour l'instant les russes
occupent ces zones du sud de la russie
il ya des actions de guérilla
mais qui sont pour l'instant
relativement limités par leur ampleur
et d'ailleurs on peut pas exclure que ce
soit
non pas des locaux mais mais mais des
unités des forces spéciales ukrainienne
spécialisée dans les actes de sabotage
qui ont franchi entre guillemets là non
pas la frontière mais la ligne de front
donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
guérilla massive
dans les zones du sud de la russie qui
sont alors ça ça veut pas dire que les
habitants du sont occupés sont très
contents des druides oui après il faudra
voir aussi ce qu'est ce qui se passera
au moment à l'heure à cette fameuse
contre offensive ausy alexis étrange jeu
politique qui explique aussi la volonté
de lenski d'annoncer à tout prix une
offensive
non personne c'est que les russes sont
en train d'organiser alors dans la
région de kherson également dans
l'oblast dans la région de zaporijia à
l'est ils sont en train d'organiser un
référendum
comme ce qu'il est bété falloir
maintenant papa comme la grille mais a
priori ça serait comme le nom basse ça
comme les deux républiques séparatistes
basques c'est une déclaration
d'indépendance mais pas de rattachement
à la fédération de aussi aller le
d'ailleurs le moscou n'ont pas forcément
intérêt en tout cas à court terme un
rattachement de ces territoires c'est
comme ce qu'on disait à propos de la
grille mais une fois que la russie a dit
c'est chez nous que ça veut dire qu'en
cas de
d'atteindre dès lors qu'il aura des
combats dans ces zones concrètement du
point de vue du droit russe ça sera une
guerre ouverte entre la russie et
l'ukraine vous puisque ça sera
concrètement du point de vue du droit
russe pas du point de vue du droit
international et du point de vue du
droit russe ça sera le territoire russe
mais quand on
pourrait se demander qu'est ce que ça
changerait alors qu'ils sont déjà en
guerre en ukraine ah bah ça ça change
tout ne serait ce que deux points de vue
delà de la définition des intérêts
vitaux de la russie c'est un peu dès
lors que c'est le territoire d'un pays
on arrive à des concepts comme ceux d'
intérêts vitaux
qui ont des implications militaires
très importante notamment qu'on est un
pays nucléaire comme la russie est une
des deux premières puissances nucléaires
dans le monde donc ça changerait
absolument tout ça changerait le fait
qu'il y aurait de facto il y aurait d y
aurait une guerre et donc la possibilité
d'une mobilisation générale on sait très
bien qu'aujourd'hui au kremlin ils n'ont
aucune envie qu'il y ait une
mobilisation générale si la partie la
plus jusqu'au boutiste mai mais pour
l'instant la ligne de vladimir poutine
c'est d'éviter autant que faire se peut
une mobilisation générale même si ç'a un
impact que convoiterait bien sûr la
carte c'est à dire qu'avec 150000 à
200000 hommes c'est très compliqué pour
les russes d'atteindre leurs objectifs
militaires
encore faudrait-il les connaître
exactement alors on a deux questions qui
vont se rejoindre celle de landry
qu'inutile ukraine est accusé d'avoir
bombardé la crimée qui est dans
l'orientation stratégique de kiev de
détourner l'attention des russes du nom
base donc je pense que s'ils nous
demandent comprend pensons-nous j'aime
puis van cleef ce qui veut dire c'est
que est-ce que attaqué la crimée permet
de faire partir les rues de patte du
donbass mais de moins se concentrer sur
le droit s est une autre question de la
peur de denis bellick munich que s'est
il passé à sa qui je pense que c'est la
même surface est le même even la même
actualité le même événement ce qui s'est
passé donc c'est il ya eu une explosion
vraiment considérable fois la vidéo je
vous invite à aller voir elles sont
impressionnantes dans la base de sa qui
donc est sûre la la côte crime yens
ainsi une grande base aérienne et c'est
notamment dans cette base aérienne qui
lie la les avions les aéronefs de la
delà de la marine russe et non pas de
des forces aériennes russes donc une
énorme explosion il ya eu au moins une
dizaine d'avions qui ont été détruits
des sukhoi 30
c'est un chasseur multirôle et des
sukhoï 24 qui est un vieux
bombardiers tactiques
donc c'est un coût pour les russes parce
que là la crimée encore une fois du
point de vue du droit russe donc on l'a
dit c'est la russie et ce à des
applications militaires cirque il ya
notamment
des défenses qui sont qui sont
théoriquement très puissante avec
notamment des systèmes antiaériens s 400
quel système russe le plus abouti
aujourd'hui en russie
alors voilà les les russes ont dit c'est
intéressant parce que personne allez les
deux comtés honni et sert que les russes
ont dit c'est un accident lié à une
mauvaise
un mauvais respect des règles de
sécurité alors les ukrainiens vire
ironisé sur le don de 12 explosions
jeter un mégot auprès des fai des avions
donc si on y croit on peut pas l'exclure
mais on n'y croit pas tellement mais ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que les
ukrainiens ont suggéré que c'était une
attaque de leur part mais ils n'ont pas
revendiqué cette attaque est
probablement ça avait déjà été le cas
d'ailleurs à belgorod
à la lèze de l'ukraine juste après la
frontière il avait ciblé des dépôts de
pétrole dans mon souvenir et les russes
n'avaient pas revendiqué cette attaque
et pourquoi c'est précisément pour
rester pour la demande sous des lignes
rouges russe et en même temps les russes
n'ont pas envie qu'on
met le doigt sur le fait que leur leur
leur bulle antiaérienne en crimée n'est
probablement pas aussi étanche qu'il
l'espérait voilà alors après il ya plein
de questions qui se posent et notamment
c'est c'la c'est la nature de l' attaque
les missiles dont disposent les
ukrainiens actuellement notamment les
mici le touch cas on 100 à 150 km de
portée la vouliez bien ya entre
nikolaïev et sacchi à 240 kilomètres ça
on peut exclure ça ne peut pas être delà
de l'artillerie même les high mars
américain dont on parlait tout à l'heure
c'est 70 km on est on est très loin donc
là il ya énormément de possibilités on
peut pas répondre à l'affirmative est ce
que c'est une action au sol de forces
spéciales de sabotage est ce que c'est
une attaque de drone on a vu que les
économies a été très bon pour pour
envoyer des des drones
qui large des îles hd petite charge
explosive et qui seraient passés en
dessous des défense russe ou est ce que
c'est une attaque de missiles et en là
ça ça pose des questions parce que ça ne
peut pas être des missiles ukrainien
donc c'est à dire que ça serait des
missiles corps aient été fournies par
des occidentaux et dans cette hypothèse
la problème en part des américains on
parle notamment des missiles attaque m s
alors ce sont des missiles d'ailleurs
qui sont utilisées a déployé depuis les
systèmes d'artillerie en mars quand on
partait 300 km et pour l'instant les
américains officiellement non n'ont pas
livré à l'ukraine justement pour pour
dire que leur armement ne sert pas à
taper le territoire c'est que c'est
vraiment limité à l'échelle des combats
en ukraine
et puis voilà est en revanche les
les américains avaient avoué qu'ils
avaient livré à l'ukraine des des
missiles
pour le coup tiré depuis depuis l'ère
qui sont des missiles à gm 88 qui sont
là pour cibler les défenses aériennes
adverse il ya plein d'hypothèses
possible on ne peut pas actuellement
écrit le rexall savoir exactement aimé
ça mais c'est un gros choc pour les pour
les russes parce que précisément là les
ukrainiens ont montré aux russes qu'il
était capable de faire ce que les
ukrainiens sont depuis le début les gars
c'est à dire frapper le territoire
enfin les russes frappe le territoire
ukrainien dans toute sa profondeur
depuis le 24 février il ya eu des
frappes alif à l'extrême orient et les
pays bas là ça montre que les ukrainiens
sont capables de faire un peu la même
chose et d'attaquer
politiquement des symboles de la
politique
expansionniste de ruswil crâne
effectivement et alors là l'autre
question qui était je vois que l'été à
côté sur est ce que ça peut permettre de
détourner l'attention finalement des
russes qui vont plus se concentrer sur
cette zone là que non parce que là les
enjeux ne sont pas les mêmes c'est pas
des enjeux
terrestre c'est plus un des enjeux de
défense aérienne de radars et autres
donc nous ils vont ils vont pas pour
cette raison ont enlevé des troubles du
thon basse et les mettre en fait mais en
revanche ce qu'on a vu depuis quelques
semaines c'est qu'il ya eu des troupes
du don basques ont été redéployés à
carson parce que pour le coup à carson
la menace à laquelle et les russes sont
confrontés c'est bien celle d'une
offensive terrestre même si on a dit que
cette offensive terrestre à ce jeu on
n'avait que très peu de chances
d'aboutir alors on allait me dis merci
beaucoup de votre réponse une guerre
donc de mots vision générale des russes
poserait des gros problèmes logistiques
selon lui pour les russes qui ont montré
une grande faiblesse dans ce domaine
louis c'est ce qu'on disait puis oui
c'est en fait je vois qui mobilisera une
faiblesse historique de l'armée russe
et oui ça serait difficile en plus elle
sera difficile pour les pour lui pour
les russes même s'ils ont encore des
réserves et et on le voit sur plein de
question d'être notamment les les
missiles justement de précision qui
l'utilisé contre l'ukraine ils ont
utilisé tirer plus de 2500 peut-être
aujourd'hui à près de 3000 initialement
le 24 février tous les experts pensaient
que les russes on avait entre 1500 et
2000 voilà il continue en utiliser alors
certes des missiles de plus en plus
anciens
ou des missiles dont la destination à
l'origine n'est pas la frappe contre
terre mais par exemple la lutte
antinavire
mais malgré tout les rues sont encore et
il y avait une chose intéressante c'est
que les russes commencent à utiliser
pour frapper des objectifs terrestres
des missiles anti aériens s 300 alors il
ya pas mal d'experts enfin de gens
comment réagit au départ en dix ans
s'il ne soit pas c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour les rues parce que c'est
vraiment la preuve qu'ils sont en cours
domicile il ya d'autres experts qu'on
dit oui mais attendez c'est quand même
aussi une très mauvaise nouvelle parce
que on sait très bien depuis des années
que les s-300 peuvent avoir une fonction
de frappe et frappe contre terre et pour
le coup des missiles s 300 qui sont
fabriqués depuis 20 ans depuis 30 je
peux pas dire de bêtises mais même 40
ans la la la russie à des dizaines de
ses des dizaines de milliers de ces
missiles en stock et donc ça lui permet
de ça lui permettrait de tenir très
longtemps alors on est une question de
de nathan qui ne devait pas être là au
début du live on va répéter c'est pas
grave et en notes et un même trop se
répéter mais pas trop non plus mais ils
nous demandent où en est-on qu'aux
questions de gains territoriaux forces
en présence et pertes depuis depuis ces
derniers mois et un documentaire inédit
le rouleau compresseur russe semble
inexorable ce qu'on dit c'est qu'en
termes de gains territoriaux depuis un
mois ça n'a pas beaucoup bougé alors jeu
va se répéter très rapidement donc
130000 120 130 mille kilomètres carrés
c'est les gains russe en ukraine mais y
compris ceux de 2014 c'est à peu près la
taille de la grèce mais ce que je disais
c'est que pas un an en juillet les gains
territoriaux russes se sont limités à
quelques dizaines voire centaines de km²
donc peanuts par rapport à l'ensemble ça
montre bien qu'il ya un tassement de
l'avancée de l'avancé russes maintenant
sur les forces en présence
pareil on
on l'a dit mais les ordres de grandeur
du côté russe sont toujours les mêmes
150 à
200 mille hommes peut-être un peu moins
aujourd'hui
modulo les les pertes et la capacité de
complétion pas de renouvellement des des
pertes
sachant que donc les russes sont appelle
beaucoup de plus en plus à des
volontaires dans les régions
périphériques de la russie
qui d'ailleurs souvent ne sont pas être
uniquement russe
et pourquoi pas ce qu'ils payent très
bien
on a fait un article aussi figaro ont
donné les salles est entre guillemets
non dans certaines régions c'est de
l'ordre de 1000 voire 5000 euros par
mois ce qui est absolument énorme en
russie et surtout dans les régions
pauvres de la russie mais malgré tout
est-ce que ça va couvrir les pertes
c'est pas certain sur le niveau des
pertes tous les chiffres ont été avancés
récemment on disait 80 mille pertes
alors les pertes c'est pas seulement les
morses aussi les blessés et les
prisonniers
franchement c'est très difficile à dire
parce qu'il ya une guerre des chiffres
qui était parti là la guerre du manager
ce soit des deux côtés ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il ya eu énormément de
pertes notamment enfin pour la russie
notamment dans les deux premiers mois de
la guerre puisque là la grande offensive
du nord vers kiev depuis la biélorussie
et depuis le nord ouest de la russie
a été quand même d'un peu de vittek
tactique un échec militaire pour la pour
la russie ce qui éclaire aussi c'est
qu'il ya des pertes ukrainienne qui sont
très importantes probablement plus
d'ailleurs depuis la réorientation de la
guerre vers le dombass
puisque les les autorités ukrainiennes
elle-même un moment avancé des chiffres
de
considérable je veux pas dire de métis
était peut-être 5000 par semaine ou
qu'il perde pas semaine quasiment 1000
par par par jour je suis considérable je
salue christian toussaint vous êtes très
nombreux à nous poser des questions
actuellement donc c'est compliqué de
répondre à tout le monde on a une vraie
peut-être une question un peu rapide
hanifa qui me demande est ce que
l'ukraine a refusé le contrôle de la
centrale nucléaire car d'autres
personnes pourraient confirmer qu'elle a
été bien été bombardé par le jeu on a
déjà répondu à cette question donc je
vais rapidement oui pour l'instant elle
refuse le contrôle de la ive a pour
plusieurs raisons elle a pas envie de
légitimer la présence russe dans cette
centrale et puis elle demande l le
prérequis qu'elle demande c'est une zone
démilitarisée
au niveau de la centrale et puis oui
hélas peuvent peut-être c'est une
hypothèse qu'on ne peut pas l'affirmer
où il ya eu peut-être probablement des
tirs d'artillerie ukrainien à proximité
de la centrale alors on a et d'art qui
nous parle de deux choses dingues in
parle déjà de odessa de la ville
d'odessa est-ce que ça peut constituer
toujours un objectif côté côté russe
à très long terme oui
et à très long terme oui mais pour
l'instant c'est plus du tout d'actualité
oui parce que c'est loin encore on l'a
dit encore une fois pour l'instant le
front du sud l'avancée russe vers
l'ouest pour l'instant non seulement
elle est à l'arrêt mais les russes sont
sur la défensive
à carson et même s'il arrivait à
relancer la machine entre guillemets il
faudrait d'abord qu'ils aillent amis que
la caf et la ville juste à côté
et ensuite seulement il faudrait qu'ils
aillent vers odessa mais pour l'instant
on n'en est pas du tout là et vu le
rythme de la guerre en ukraine
c'est impossible
jusqu'à d'ici l'automne après ça sera
l'hiver qui en général peu propice peu
propice d'opérations militaires donc là
on se projette à long terme c'était en
et là on peut faire
plein d'hypothèses que là est ce que
pour le coup on sera arrivé un point
culminant de la guerre tels que la
guerre s'arrêtera à peu près à ce niveau
là où il y aura une relance russe ou à
la personne de relance ne craignait mais
pour l'instant c'est complètement
hypothétique en revanche dans la tête du
kremlin on peut imaginer que odessa
revêtent un intérêt
stratégique très important puisque ça
priverait
la l'ukraine d'un accès à la mer et on a
vu depuis plusieurs mois maintenant que
les russes ont un vrai problème qui est
que leur flotte de la mer noire
et jules l'érable on l'a vu avec la
destruction du sila va mais au delà et
la de cela chez sébastopol et à 3 300 km
douter ça et là ce qu'a montré aussi la
tacc delà de la base de sa qui sait que
les ukrainiens ont une capacité d'action
contre la crème et est donc cette
vulnérabilité de la flotte de la mer
noire pour les russes c'est
insupportable et ça a été vraiment
révélées par la gangrène c'était je
pense en grande partie une inimaginable
pour les pour le pour les russes qui
avait un peu tendance à penser à tort
d'ailleurs que là que la mer noire était
un la gredine déjà ça lag russo turque
je vais quand même une grande
mais le mais là on voit que les russes
sont vulnérables et justement on avait
aussi une autre question des nerfs qui
demande une bradl delisle-houde l'île
aux serpents le l'île des serpents qui
n'a pas bon alors c'est ce petit point
bleu vous voyez sur la carte qui était
occupé par les rues par les rayons repli
se remplit pas tactiquement à
longlaville an note john o'dell rec
tactiquement ça n'a pas de sens en fait
non c'est vrai aucun sens de tenir
c'était une guerre d'usure
qui était qu'ils n'avaient aucun intérêt
militaire qui avait à la rigueur en
intérêts symboliques et politiques pour
les ukrainiens mais pas pour les russes
est par ailleurs l'arrivée de la retirer
à longue portée dont je parlais faisait
que tenir cette île pour les russes
étaient de plus en plus difficile mais
inversement je me souviens qu'on avait
dit que c'est pas parce que les russes
ils étaient partis que les ukrainiens
les revenir puisque les ukrainiens
allait se confond est confronté aux
mêmes problèmes que les russes et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est passé donc
ils l'île aux serpents est vide depuis
depuis leur pyrrhus ils sont juste aller
déposer un drapeau ukrainien puissant
parti mais mais pour l'instant l'île des
serpents et l'île aux serpents n'est
plus un enjeu elle pourra leur devenir
encore une fois très long terme si
jamais il y avait une une offensive
russe vers l'ouest de l'ukraine mais
pour l'instant on en est très très très
très loin alors on a un commentaire de
qui n'a pas de qui n'a pas de pseudo et
qui me dit le front principal toujours
dans le bon ben voilà on a parlé quand
même boucle oui mais on ne va pas il
faut quand même parler du thon casse
puisque le donbass c'est quand même une
zone aussi où des combats font rage hop
voilà vous voyez ici sur la carte mais
dans le donbass est ce que les choses
évoluent vraiment depuis un mois alors
là plus du territoire y aller les choses
ont très peu avancé dont je rappelle là
on voit bien ça fait une forme de
peu de croissance mais ça je vais pas
comment dire mais mais si vous voulez ya
donc le donbass ces deux régions
le lougansk
nord-est et et dounia sq au sud est sud
ouest à côté l'une de l'autre donc là
les séparatistes avait appris grosso
modo la moitié de ces deux territoires
en 2014 et donc là l'objectif officiel
de 2 du kremlin c'est de prendre
l'intégralité de ces deux oblast on se
souvient que les russes avaient assez
vite avancé à lougansk est que la
dernière étape ça a été la ville
de severodonezk qui a été prise début
juillet et qui on va dire ça ça a
chauffé la conquête par les russes de
l'intégralité le blast de l'union ce qui
était une première
victoire un premier objectif politique
et militaire maintenant le deuxième
c'est le blast 2 dawn est hélas si vous
voulez y à il ya deux chapelets de
villes tchèques les russes avancent
globalement le meut la manoeuvre c'est
qu'ils avancent et parle par l'est et
par le nord c'est que par le nord ils
ont également conquis peut-être que tu
peux revenir à la carte bancaire plus
généralement on voit mieux où il à la
manoeuvre globalement c'est en tenaille
à la fois par le sud s'il parle de le
dombass contrôlée par les séparatistes
depuis 2014 par l'est par ces vers de
ness et par le nord puisque en fait les
russes contrôlent une partie de la place
de kharkiv avec la ville centrale de 18
mai sauf que depuis leur basse le
mouvement de taux n'aille russe
n'a pas avancé et
alors la raison principale qui ne
raisons structurelles on il ya un tout
petit peu tout à l'heure c'est que les
russes ont une martyre est extrêmement
puissante mais en revanche il manque
cruellement de d'infanterie c'est à dire
tout simplement des fantassins au sol
pour pour aller engager le combat après
que l'artillerie à lionel
est donc là les russes manquent de
manque d'hommes et des dons qu'ils
n'avancent pas il ya en fait une c plus
là une guerre de manoeuvre c'est une
guerre d'attrition une guerre d'usure
c'est dire en chaque adversaire essaye
de d'affaiblir l'autre et c'est à celui
qui tiendra le plus longtemps
au début enfin dans le donbass les
russes semblent en termes d'attrition
avoir quand même le l'ascendant sur les
sur les ukrainiens mais mais pas
suffisamment pour créer un effondrement
même local de l'armée ukrainienne ya pas
eu d'effondrement locales dans le bon
base de l'armée ukrainienne pour
l'instant ils ont conservé même dans les
parties qui l'ont quitté ils ont
conservé une capacité de repli quand il
a abandonné un territoire à peu près
dans le bonheur maintenant on va voir ce
que ce qu'il en est là que je pense que
tu peux pour le coup revenir la carte
d'après
qui est ici en fait il ya deux il ya 2
le 2 ligne de ville enfin l'objectif
principal c'est les deux villes convoi
slovenské creator formateur ce qui est
la capitale ukrainienne de le blaze de
dounia sq depuis que 2000 2014 de la
ville de dominer et séparatistes donc ça
s'est laissé deux villes de plus de 100
milliards cent mille habitants
donc c'est un gros enjeu les
severodonetsk et l'isi chance les deux
dernières villes de l'union c'était
aussi à peu près les mêmes tant de
grandeur mais avant ça les russes
doivent faire tomber la ligne de défense
ukrainienne qui situe actuellement voix
dans les deux villes de six verres sq et
bach route s'ils versent ces dix mille
habitants c'est une petite ville et bah
knut c'est à dire des bêtises 70 me dont
80 mille habitants alors pour l'instant
ils ont abandonné une sorte de pause
opérationnelle au niveau de six verres
sq probablement pour une raison assez
simple c'est que si c'est le terrain de
monde vers l'ouest c'est à dire qu'en
fait les les ukrainiens selon les
auteurs et donc ça c'est un avantage
énorme sac aussi les russes avant ça a
découvert avec les ukrainiens qui les
pilotent par le haut c'est c'est très
compliqué donc le front ainsi vers ce
cas très peu avancé ces dernières
semaines il a plus avancé vers ben aknou
t au sud de bagdad on a l'impression que
les rues les russes exercent une
pression de plus en plus forte mais pour
l'instant sans qu'on voie un
effondrement d'ukrainiens et si on
revient à pardon à la carte d'avant
où on voit vraiment le front du sud du
donbass on voit là la capitale de niasse
qu en fait les fortifications
ukrainienne les plus puissantes sont à
ce niveau là et jusqu'à présent les
russes n'avaient pas du tout attaqué
dans cette direction parce qu'il y avait
peu d'intérêt militaire attaquer là on
doit attaquer la ligne maginot ce qu'on
remarque depuis quelques
depuis une semaine ou deux
c'est de toutes petites percées russe
sur cette ligne maginot
mais il est trop tôt pour dire ce qu'ils
ont ce qu'il en sera
voilà je franchement il est trop tôt
mais mais mais le constat c'est que les
russes n'ont pas avancé depuis un mois
dans cette région la preuve cette carte
je lève ou complètement elle date du 6
juillet c'est partant celle ci voilà
l'autre elle est à jour celle ci date du
6 juillet on est peu de chose n'a pas
remise à un jour mais mais franchement
la carte est quasiment la même est ce
que je vous disais c'est qu'il ya une
pression légèrement accrue autour de
bach mouthe c'est tout et back mühle qui
est un peu plus bas comme on vous le dit
citoyen voilà dans le dos deux nièces
qu'un peu plus bas on avait une question
alors seulement on va pouvoir parler des
scénarios pour le futur hainard qui
demande combien de temps de tenir
l'ukraine au rythme où vont les pertes
en fait comment pour eux c'est une bonne
question mais personne n'a la réponse à
cette question mais c'est cela la
question se pose du côté ukrainien et du
côté russe quand est ce que la russie
sonnera la mobilisation générale aussi
mais on ne sait pas s'ils le font en
tout cas il ya un lien si vous voulez
dans la pression il ya la pression en
sommes et la pression au matériel alors
justement à boules qui me dit est ce que
la russie mobilise toute sa flotte
maritime et sa flotte aérienne est-ce
que s'il faudrait prendre l'ukraine plus
facilement là la flotte maritime nenê
n'est pas l'enjeu
la guerre en ukraine n'est que
secondaire menant une guerre navale donc
ça c'est pas un enjeu et la flotte
aérienne on va dire que pour l'instant
les russes sont je crois que les
derniers chiffres que j'avais c'était
200 ou 300 sorties aériennes par jour
donc c'est pas négligeable dans le
donbass a un impact puissant avec des
avions d'attaqué au sol
en revanche ils ne sont pas complètement
maîtres de l'ensemble du théâtre aérien
ukrainien parce que tout simplement il
ya encore des défenses aériennes
ukrainienne
et on sait qu'il ya des faiblesses de
l'armée de ramer dollar us le manque de
deux heures de vol des pilotes à un
manque de munitions guidées enfin dites
complexes
voilà mais si vous voulez donc il ya la
pression nommé il ya la pression en
matériel et ça se pose à la fois pour
l'ukraine et pour l'épauler russe pour
l'ukraine l'attrition un homme en
apparence ça n'est pas un problème
puisqu'ils ont sonné la mobilisation
générale néanmoins sonné aussi hein
parce que
des gens qui n'ont pas d'expérience du
combat qui n'ont pas de formation ça
vaut pas autant qu'un soldat fort mais
qui se bat depuis 2014 sur le fond du
dombass est par ailleurs former une
armée entière ça prend des mois moins
deux mois donc contrairement aux
apparences l'attrition un homme est
aussi un problème côté ukrainien côté
russe c'est une évidence puisqu'ils
n'ont pas sonné la mobilisation générale
donc ils s'appuient sur des volontaires
mais en auront-ils suffisamment voilà
c'est une question difficile et
maintenant du côté de de l'attrition
matériel la russie a un avantage elle
est une sorte de profondeur en termes de
stocks qui vient tout simplement des
stocks soviétique
les russes tir s'est pas exactement mais
vingt trente mille certain 19 50 mille
bus par jour c'est absolument
considérable tout ça est permis par le
fait que la russie a des stocks
soviétique d'armement considérable et
qu'on avait peut-être sous-estimé par
exemple à l'endroit des missiles
maintenant ça ne suffit pas enfin ce
stock n'est pas infini et donc est ce
que le complexe industriel russe est
capable de renouveler les stocks et ça
c'est une réponse franchement on n'a pas
on l'a pas côté ukrainien c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure je ne vais pas me
répéter mais c'est le passage
d'armement principalement c'est
l'éthique à des armements
étant donné que on sait très bien que
les armées occidentales ont très peu de
stock c'est à dire que l'on n'a donné
qu'une dizaine de plus d'une dizaine de
canon caesar ça peut paraître très peu
mais en réalité c'est très abstrait ment
pas négligeable au regard du nombre de
canon caesar que possède l'armée
française là encore je veux pas dire de
bêtises mais je crois que c'est 60 ou 70
minorité c'est important et il ya les
matériels les canons et puis après il ya
les missions donc voilà tout ça et même
les américains qui ont une base de coûts
plus importantes
pareil la part de missiles javelin c'est
les missiles porté à l'épaule qui ont
été très utiles pour les ukrainiens au
début la au début de la guerre
les américains se sont départis d'une
part non négligeable de leurs de leurs
stocks et comme les armements
occidentaux sont plus complexes dans
certes meilleure plus précis tout ce que
voulait que les armements russes ils
sont aussi plus long à fabriquer et plus
chère et plus coûteux donc ça c'est le
grand enjeu est franchement personne
aujourd'hui n'est capable de répondre à
la question qui gagnera cette guerre
d'attrition voilà donc c'est au plus ça
ça répond aussi à la énarque mais
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être déterminant
pour permettre une fin de cette guerre
me dit est ce qu'il ya des scénarios
aujourd'hui sur le long terme est ce que
on peut savoir voilà alors certes de la
prédiction ne peut pas savoir forcément
mais
c'est de la prospective on est en train
de préparer un papier qui manque encore
en ligne sur cette question là il le
sera dans quelques semaines avec des
cartes en fait plus que des scénarios il
faut avoir un calendrier en tête c'est à
dire qu' on ne peut pas imaginer
de grands changements territoriaux d'ici
la fin de l'automne et la femme automne
tout va être gelé jusqu'à l'an dire que
d'ici la fin de l'automne on ne peut pas
imaginer je les dis une grande offensive
ukrainienne
dans le sud de l'ukraine qui irait
jusqu'à remettre en cause remettre en
cause la crimée russe on peut au mieux
pour les ukrainiens imaginé voilà qui
reprennent à la rive droite du du diable
donc à la halle ouest d'hier et côté
russe on peut envisager une avancée dans
le fort encore dans le combat on n'est
même pas sûr à ce stade vous la pause
opérationnelle et difficultés
rulhe sur le terrain on peut même pas
imaginer que d'ici
la fin de l'automne on peut l'imaginer
mais c'est pas garanti qu'ils obtiennent
leur le afin qu'il réussisse atteint
l'objectif de contrôler l'intégralité du
no mas donc voilà ça c'est les ordres de
grandeur à l'échelle de l'automne
ensuite il y aura probablement
une pause entre guillemets il y aura
toujours des combats face à des combats
pendant l'hiver
en parallèle il y aura peut-être des
négociations qui dépendront de de l'état
des forces en présence et après tout la
question c'est qu'est-ce qui se passera
au début de l'année 2000 23 et donc là
est ce que les russes ou encore les
moyens de pousser en avant
au delà du donbass il ya beaucoup de
disques aux russes aujourd'hui qui parle
de la région de kharkiv qui est donc au
nord du nom basse
mais on l'a dit déjà très souvent ici
mais kharkiv c'est la deuxième ville
d'ukraine c'est un million et demi
d'habitants donc une guerre urbaine dans
cette ville assez considérable c'est
mario paul c'était quatre cent mille
habitants on a c'est un million et demi
un million et demi d'habitants c'est
l'intégralité de la population de la
tchétchénie
c'est vraiment très important ou est ce
que les russes pousseront plus tôt vers
l'ouest et vers rodez ça
on n'en sait rien peut-être que
d'ailleurs ils consolideront plutôt leur
le regain actuel et côté ukrainien
quelles seraient les marges de manoeuvre
est ce que c'est continué de grignoter
les gares russes dans le sud de
l'ukraine est ce que c'est grignoter les
gares russes autour de kharkiv qui sont
déjà assez important en termes
territoriaux
voilà mes mais pour l'instant c'est ces
hypothétiques on peut faire que des
grands scénarios de prospective mais en
tout cas il faut garder le calendrier à
l'horizon des prochains mois il faut pas
s'attendre sauf retournement qui est
toujours possible dans la guerre il faut
a priori pas s'attendre à un grand
chamboulement de la carte et donc on
suivra ça et puis on les rase papier qui
sortira d'ici plus au lendemain du 6 2 3
6 2 de troisième que vous pourrez lire
sur le fit sur le site du figaro alors
j'avais une question sur sa sueur
rapport d'amnesty dont on a parlé
rapidement débuter au début de ce direct
il ya une polémique autour d'amnesty
international qui qui a sorti un rapport
à ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qui s'est passé oui en fait ce que le
rapport dit à grands traits c'est que
les ukrainiens
se bat y compris depuis des positions
civiles ou se servent de position de
civils comme des écoles des hôpitaux etc
pour y mettre des états majors des
houles ou simplement le repos des
soldats
qu'ils se battent depuis des positions
civiles sans faire parfois attention aux
civils
donc le
destin international a rapporté ria
certain nombre de faits 19 dont souvenir
dans 19 localités
alors en fait la position d'amnesty
international elle est très classique
delà de la philosophie du droit des
conflits armés moderne
du droit international humanitaire tel
qu'il est fait aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que c'est hors ces organismes veille a
appliqué de la même façon le droit
international quel que soit le statut ou
de débit les gérants qui ce que
l'agresseur et l'agressé sont les mêmes
règles et les règles je vais pas les
répéter c'est ce qu'on avait dit tout à
l'heure on n'a pas le droit on a le
droit de ne l'utiliser de manière
militaire que des objectifs militaires
donc pas des objectifs civils avec plein
de subtilité qu'on avait évoqué donc
c'est ça ce que ce que fait ce qui est
dit
amnesty international par ailleurs on
avait vu depuis plusieurs mois des
reportages ou des réseaux sociaux qui
montrait déjà que les que les ukrainiens
bas
combattez en ville mais mais mais en
même temps
la réponse des ukrainiennes peut
s'entendre aussi des chants de leur
ville et défendre leurs villages voilà
où et ça c'est moins
acceptable qui les utilisaient des
écoles des hôpitaux etc comme com com
comme biens militaires
donc voilà ce qu'on peut dire mais donc
ça c'est la partie on va dire technique
juridique mais après il ya la question
politique c'est qu'évidemment
pour les russes c'est une aubaine
puisque c'est quelque chose qui dise
depuis extrêmement longtemps que la
servir leur probable mais on le voit
dans tous les conflits c'est déjà ce
qu'on voyait en syrie ce qu'on voyait on
ira consulter les en 2003 quand c'était
les américains cave et qui avaient
envahi l'irak il y avait un cas célèbre
d'un hôpital bref qu'elle était
bombardée et à la fois les américains
aient fait quelque chose qui était non
conforme au droit international et en
même temps évidemment l'armée irakienne
de saddam hussein avaient utilisé les
civils comme comme comme bouclier et
donc là on est dans une dialectique
politique entre zelensky et la russie la
russie dit vous voyez la véraison
les ukrainiens utiliser populations
civiles russophone du dombass comme de
bouclier ils n'ont rien à faire là sur
des populations civiles et les
ukrainiens 10 mais attendez c'est qu'ils
sont furieux parce que euh c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure en tout cas
au début de la guerre il était dans une
logique de asymétrique face à la russie
donc évidemment il
il n'allait pas y aller par chercher le
combat donc dans les grandes plaines il
n'allait pas rechercher les combats de
chars il allait préférer
des combats urbains déjà pour tenir
villes qui sont les leurs et ensuite
parce que militairement c'est un
avantage il ya un avantage aux
défenseurs dans les villes qui étaient
très importants et par les pleins de
fois donc voilà voilà ce qu'on peut dire
peut-être un dernier point c'est que
zelensky il a eu plusieurs ratés de
communication il ya quelques nuages
noirs qu'on observe
il ya eu le rapport d'amnesty
international qui mine de rien je pense
un effet un impact sur la sur les
opinions publiques notamment
occidentales il ya eu par ailleurs la
presse allemande qui s'est fait de
nouveaux éco
du fait que c'est le nom d'hélène ce qui
était quand même dans les panama paper
sans terme de l'exil fiscal ça ne s'est
pas très bon pour poser les skis en ce
moment et puis de manière générale il ya
quelque chose qui n'est pas bon pour les
ukrainiens c'est que l'ukraine
passionnément les foules l'intérêt
médiatique pour le cren
diminué c'est absolument flagrant si
l'on observe les les chiffres parlant de
google ou des chiffres sur les réseaux
sociaux les occurrences demi mot ukraine
sont littéralement il faudrait là encore
une fois on le voit dans tous les
conflits mais mais ça forcément d'une
manière ou d'une autre un impact sur les
politiques occidentales pas forcément de
manière complètement corrélés mais à la
fin ce sera un impact et pour l'ukraine
le danger c'est de voir
ras-le-bol progressif de l'occident et
un soutien qui s'étonneraient alors
justement sur ce soutien on a mis les
dernières choses c'est que l'autre noir
noir pour poser lenski c'est aussi qu'
on commence à avoir très fortement
ycompris y compris en occident l'impact
de la guerre économique sur l'inflation
c'est ce dont parle hélas il n'y en cas
de crise économique l'europe
pourrait-elle lâché l'ukraine on n'a pas
la réponse à cette question et je ne
pense pas qu'il lâcherait tout bonnement
l'ukraine mais en revanche on voit par
exemple les syndicats allemands qui
commença
à être vraiment très très inquiet de la
situation et l'hiver prochain parce que
l'allemagne est dans une situation
extrêmement délicate et que si elle doit
fermer partiellement ses usines cet
hiver ça sera un drame pour l'allemagne
on a déjà vu ça a été vécue comme un
traumatisme
la balance commerciale allemande est
devenue déficitaire je crois que c'était
le mois dernier ça n'était jamais arrivé
en allemagne depuis 1991 donc voilà
toutes ces choses là ne sont pas
excellentes pour l'ukraine maintenant il
faut pas non plus oublier que la
situation politique intérieure pour la
russie n'est pas non plus et lente même
s'il n'ya pas eu l'effondrement de
l'économie russe qui avait probablement
été annoncée beaucoup trop prestement
par par les ministres occidentaux nous
notamment par bruno le maire on a vu que
le rouble et en bonne santé que que les
les revenus de l'industrie
pétrolière russe ont continué
d'augmenter même si les volumes
diminuent mais parce que les prix
augmenter et que c'était en revanche la
production russe industriel russe on
voit qu'elle avait énormément baissé il
ya tout un tas de défis en termes de
substitution aux importations
à cause des sanctions qui font que la
situation économique pour la russie est
quand même très délicate à jouer
justement vous montrer ses papiers qui
est une vérification qui a été fait hier
sur le site du figaro qui est ici la
plus la sanction ont-elles fait de la
russie une puissance alimentaire laisser
les centrales de 2014 articles
intéressants d'autre de fabrice naudé
langlois vous pourrez retrouver
effectivement alors il est bientôt 13
heures du coup on va arrêter cela il
merci vous êtes très très nombreux à
nous poser encore vos questions mais je
pense qu'on a à peu près répondu à tous
vous pouvez bien sûr retrouver ce live
retrouvez les vous le voit en replay on
aura sûrement répondu une vision
peut-être très rapidement et les filles
et un de nos fidèles du coup le temps
joue plutôt pour les ukrainiens pour les
russes alors c'est un peu ce qu'on avait
commencé à dire non l'année dernière
question franchement il sait comme il
n'est pas parce qu'il n'est il n'est pas
possible de répondre à cette question de
manière affirmative
les éléments de réponse et d'un point de
vue militaire on n'a pas la réponse à la
question la guerre d'attrition qui va la
gagner
et économiquement en termes de soutien
là encore une sorte de bras de fer et on
n'a pas non plus la réponse à la
question il ya ces éléments que je vous
ai donné sur le désintérêt occidentales
sur la crainte de l'inflation etc mais
encore une fois la situation ici n'est
est très très loin d'être d'être au beau
fixe très bien merci beaucoup alexis
merci à vous d'avoir été très nombreux à
nous suivre minos qui nous dit on merci
vous pouvez bien évidemment retrouver
cette vidéo en replay à la fois sur site
du figaro est à la fois sur youtube
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à notre chaîne youtube pour voir
d'autres live comme ceux ci puissent
qu'on en fait quand même assez
régulièrement et moi je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
figaro live